so like if you have an llm training and
a bunch of books that cover different
economic theories and then you have
those other alums just talk to each
other like reason the way we kind of
debate each other as humans on Twitter
in uh formal debates in podcast
conversations we kind of have little
kernels of wisdom here and there but if
you can
like a thousand X speed that up
can you actually arrive somewhere new
like what's the point of conversation
really well you can tell when you're
talking to somebody you can tell
sometimes you have a conversation you're
like wow this person does not have any
original thoughts they are basically
echoing things that other people have
told them there's other people you have
a conversation with where it's like wow
like they have a model in their head of
how the world works and it's a different
model than mine and they're saying
things that I don't expect and so I need
to Now understand how their model the
world differs from my model of the world
and then that's how I learn something
fundamental right underneath underneath
the words well I wonder how uh
consistently and strongly can an LM hold
on to a world view you tell it to hold
on to that and defend it for
like for your life uh because I feel
like they'll just keep converging
towards each other they'll keep
convincing each other as opposed to
being stubborn the way humans
can so you you can experiment with this
now I do this for fun so you can tell
gpt4 you know whatever debate X you know
X and Y communism and fascism or
something and it'll it'll go for you
know a couple pages and then inevitably
it wants the parties to agree yeah and
so they will come to a common
understanding and it's very funny if
they're like if these are like
emotionally inflammatory topics because
they're like somehow the machine is just
you know figures out a way to make them
agree but it doesn't have to be like
that and you because you can add to the
prompt
um we I do not want the I do not want
the conversation to come in agreement in
fact I want it to get you know more
stressful right uh and argumentative
right
um you know as it goes like I want I
want tension to come out I want them to
become actively hostile to each other I
want them to like you know not trust
each other take anything at face value
yeah and it will do that it's happy to
do that so it's going to start rendering
misinformation uh about the other but
it's good you can stir it you can steer
it or you could steer it you could say I
want it to get as cancer argumentative
possible but still not involve any
misrepresentation I want you know both
sides you could say I want both sides to
have good faith you could say I want
both sides to not be constrained a good
faith in other words like you can set
the parameters of the debate and it will
happily execute whatever path because
for it it's just like predicting don't
get totally happy to do either one it
doesn't have a point of view it has a
default way of operating but it's happy
to operate in the other realm
um and so like and this is how how I
when I want to learn about a contentious
issue this is what I do now it's like
this is what I this is what I ask it to
do and I'll often ask it to go through
five six seven you know different you
know sort of continuous prompts and
basically okay argue that out in more
detail okay no this this argument's
becoming too polite you know make it
more you know make it tenser
um and yeah it's thrilled to do it so it
has the capability for sure how do you
know what is true so this is very
difficult thing in the internet but it's
also a difficult thing maybe it's a
little bit easier but
uh I think it's still difficult maybe
it's more difficult I don't know with an
llm to know that it just make some
up as I'm talking to it
um how do we get that right like is your
investigating a difficult topic
because I find that alums are quite
nuanced
in a very refreshing way like it doesn't
it doesn't feel biased like uh when you
read news articles and uh tweets and
just content produced by people they
usually have this
you can tell they have a very strong
perspective where they're hiding they're
not stealing Manning the other side
they're hiding important information or
they're fabricating information in order
to make their argument stronger that's
just like that feeling maybe it's the
suspicion maybe it's mistrust with llms
it feels like none of that is there
she's kind of like yours says well we
know but you don't know if some of those
things are kind of just straight up made
up
yeah so so several layers to the
question so one is one of the things
that an llm is good at is actually deep
biasing
um and so you can feed it a news article
and you can tell it strip out the bias
yeah that's nice right and it actually
does it like it actually knows how to do
that because it knows how to do among
other things it actually knows how to do
sentiment analysis and so it knows how
to pull out the emotionality yeah
um and so uh that's one things you can
do it's very suggestive of the the the
the sense here that there's there's real
potential on this issue
um you know I would say look the second
thing is there's this there's this issue
of hallucination right um and there's a
long conversation that we could have
about that Hallucination is uh coming up
with things that are totally not true
but sound true yeah so it's basically
well so it's sort of Hallucination is
what we call it when we don't like it
creativity is what we call it when we do
like it right
um and you know brilliant right and and
so when the engineers talk about it
they're like this is terrible it's
hallucinating right if you have an
artistic inclinations you're like oh my
God we've invented creative machines for
the first time in human history this is
amazing uh uh you know bullshitters well
but but also in the good sense
of that word there's there's there are
Shades of Gray though it's interesting
so we had this conversation where you
know we're looking at my firm at Ai and
lots of domains and one of them is the
legal domain so we had this this
conversation with this big Law Firm
about how they're thinking about using
this stuff and we we went in with the
assumption that an llm that was going to
be used in the legal industry would have
to be 100 truthful all right verified
you know there's this case where this
lawyer apparently submitted a GPT uh
generated brief and it had like fake you
know legal case citations in it and the
judge was gonna he's gonna get his law
license stripped or something right so
so like we we just assumed it's like
obviously they're going to want the
super literal like you know one that
never makes anything up not the creative
one but actually they said with what the
law firm basically said is yeah that's
true at like the level of individual
briefs but they said when you're
actually trying to figure out like legal
arguments right like you you actually
you you actually want to be creative
right you don't again there's creativity
and then there's like making stuff up
like what's the line you actually want
it you want to explore a different
hypotheses right you want to do kind of
the legal version of like improv or
something like that where you want to
float different theories of the case and
different possible Arguments for the
judge and different possible Arguments
for the jury by the way different routes
through the you know sort of history of
all the of all the case law and so they
said actually for a lot of what we want
to use it for we actually want it in
creative mode and then basically we just
assume that we're going to have to
cross-check all of the um you know all
the specific citations and so I think I
think there's could be more Shades of
Gray in here than people think
um and then I just add to that you know
another one of these trillion dollar
kind of questions is ultimately you know
sort of the verification thing and so um
you know is will will llms be evolved
from here to be able to do their own
fascial verification
um will you have sort of add-on
functionality like like well from alpha
right where um you know and other
plugins where where that's the way you
do the verification you know another by
the way another idea is you might have a
community of LMS on any you know so for
example you might have the creative LM
and then you might have the literal llm
fact check it right and so there's a
variety of different technical
approaches that are being applied to
solve the hallucination problem um you
know some people like yeah lacun argue
that this is inherently an unsolvable
problem but most of the people working
in the space I think think that there's
a number of practical ways to kind of
kind of Corral this in a little bit Yeah
if you were to tell me about Wikipedia
before Wikipedia was created I would
have laughed at the possibility of
something like that being possible just
a handful of folks
can organize right and self and moderate
with a mostly unbiased way the entirety
of human knowledge I mean so if there's
something like the approach that
Wikipedia took possible from LMS
uh that's really exciting I think that's
possible and in fact Wikipedia today is
still not today is still not
deterministically correct right so you
cannot take to the bank right every
single thing on every single page but it
is probabilistically correct right and
specifically the way I describe
Wikipedia to people it is it is more
likely that Wikipedia is right than any
other source you're going to find yeah
it's this old question right of like
okay like are we looking for Perfection
are we looking for something that
asymptotically approaches uh Perfection
are we looking for something that's just
better than the Alternatives and
Wikipedia right has exactly your point
has proven to be like overwhelmingly
better than than uh than people thought
and I think I I think that's where this
this ends and then underneath all this
is the fundamental question of uh where
you started which is okay what you know
what is truth how do we get the truth
how do we know what truth is and we live
in an era in which an awful lot of
people are very confident that they know
what the truth is and I don't really buy
into that and I think the history of the
last you know 2000 years or four
thousand years of human civilization is
actually getting to the truth is
actually a very difficult thing to do
are we getting closer if we look at the
entirety The Arc of human history are we
getting closer to the truth I don't know
okay is it possible is it possible that
we're getting very far away from the
truth because of the internet because of
how rapidly you can create narratives
and just as the entirety of a society
just
move like crowds in a hysterical way
along those narratives that don't have a
necessary grounding in whatever the
truth is sure but like you know we came
up with Communism before the internet
somehow right like which was I would say
had a rather larger issues than anything
we're dealing with today we had in the
way it was implemented at issues and
this theoretical structure it had like
real issues did like a very deep
fundamental misunderstanding of human
nature and economics yeah but those
folks sure work very confident there was
the right way they were extremely
confident and my point is they were very
confident 3 900 years into what we would
presume to be Evolution towards the
truth yeah and so my my my assessment is
my assessment is number one there's no
there's no need for you know there's no
need for vehicle there's no need for the
hegelian dialectic to actually converge
towards the truth
like apparently not
um yeah so yeah so why we're so obsessed
with there being one truth is it
possible there's just going to be
multiple truths like little communities
how they believe certain things and
I think it's just now number one I think
it's just really difficult like who gets
you know historically who gets to decide
what the truth is it's either the king
or the priest right like and so we don't
live in an era anymore if kings are
priest dictating it to us and so we're
kind of on our own and so I I my my
typical thing is like we just we just
need a huge amount of humility
um and we need to be very suspicious of
people who claim that they have the
capital yeah and then we need we need to
have I know look the good news is The
Enlightenment has bequeathed us with a
set of techniques to be able to
presumably get closer to truth through
the scientific method and rationality
and observation and experimentation and
hypothesis and you know we need to
continue to embrace those even when they
give us answers we don't like sure but
uh the internet and technology has
enabled us to uh generate a large number
of content
that data uh that the process the
scientific process allows us sort of
um damages the Hope Laden within the
scientific process because if you just
have a bunch of people saying facts
on the internet and some of them are
going to be llms
you how is anything testable at all
especially that involves like human
nature and things like this there's a
lot of physics here's a question a
friend of mine just asked me on this
topic so suppose you had llms in
equivalent of ppt4 even five six seven
eight suppose you have them in the 1600s
yeah and Galileo comes up for trial yeah
right and you ask the llm like as
Galileo right yeah like what does it
answer right and one theory is it
answers no that he's wrong because the
overwhelming majority of human thought
up until that point was that he was
wrong and so therefore that's what's in
the training data yeah
um another way of thinking about it is
well it's officially Advanced llm will
have evolved the ability to actually
check the math right um and we'll
actually say actually no actually you
know you may not want to hear it but
he's right now if you know the church at
that time was you know owned the llm
they would have given it human you know
human feedback to prohibit it from
answering that question right and so I
like to take it out of our current
context because that like makes it very
clear those 10 questions apply today
right this is exactly the point of a
huge amount of the human feedback
training that's actually happening with
these LMS today this is a huge like
debate that's happening about whether
open source you know AI should be legal
or the the the actual mechanism of doing
the human RL with human feedback
is seems like such a fundamental and
fascinating question how do you select
the humans exactly
yeah how do you select the human AI
alignment right which everybody like is
like oh that's not great alignment with
what human values
whose human values who's human values so
we're and we're in this mode of like
social and popular discourse we're like
you know there's you know you see this
what do you think of when you read a
story in the Press right now and they
say you know XYZ made a baseless claim
about some topic right and there's one
group of people who are like aha think
you know they're doing fact checking
there's another group of people that are
like every time the Press says that it's
now a tech and that means that they're
lying right like
so like we're in this we're in this
social context where there's the the
level to which a lot of people in
positions of power have become very very
certain that they're in a position to
determine the truth for the entire
population is like there's like there's
like some bubble that has formed around
that idea and at least it is it flies
completely in the face of everything I
was ever trained about science and about
reason
um and Strikes me as like you know
deeply offensive um and incorrect